uh
welcome to her
welcome to the doctors talk impact on
noisy data and support vector machine
and deep learning algorithms on as
computing device
i'm i'm sorry if i mispronounced
anything dr shirang
ambiji kalkarni is
currently working as a postdoctoral
fellow with the school of global health
management and informatics university of
central florida before joining ucf he
has worked in as an associate professor
of the department of computer science
and engineering at
the national institution national
institute of engineering
mysore india
here under his phd in computer and
information science from
this vervaria
technical university in 2012 his current
research work includes developing new
algorithms for analysis of health care
data using
machine learning and uh
i'll go ahead and hand it off to you doc
you you go ahead and take over
yeah yeah thank you steven for the
wonderful introduction
and
yeah so the today's topic here is like
impact of noisy data on
support vector
[Music]
machine and deep learning algorithms on
edge computing device
the most
critical term warrior is the edge
computing device
so
we need to focus this topic in the
background of this particular
uh platform that we call it as edge
computing device
so to begin with my talk i will focus
initially on this particular platform
which we call it as the computing device
we all know that the introduction of
raspberry pi has revolutionized the
domain of internet of things
like we all knew that with internet and
with through the access of websites and
web pages
and other platforms like email and
chatting people across the world could
interact with each other it just
revolutionized the way people could
communicate with each other
but the next
or the next thing that's happening in
internet is that even objects can talk
to each other objects can control each
other and this is which we call it as
the internet of things
now these wonderful sensors when they
are
sensing the objects or sensing the
environment they produce a huge amount
of data and this huge amount of data is
transferred to the cloud where there are
certain
analytics that happen in the background
and some intelligent information is
produced now this intelligent
information is again sent back to the
user based upon which he can take some
actions
right so this is how the typical
infrastructure started developing with
internet of things
but we we
in this particular topic we are speaking
of a platform called as edge computing
which in a way is trying to argument
the capabilities of cloud computing by
reducing the amount of traffic that
flows on the network
so here we consider
things like we consider raspberry pi and
we are focused on the raspberry pi 4.
so here i have given a small depiction
of how a raspberry pi 4 can be built
into a cluster why we build input
cluster will take up further
so here we
have shown in the diagram that there is
a 8 port hub there is a master node and
there are slave nodes all these nodes
have similar capabilities of course if
we say a master node it is but natural
that if it has to
collaborate with all these slaves then
certain
higher capabilities it can have we can
think it in terms of memory and other
capabilities
since this is a small kind of setup i
have indicated the interconnecting
device
device as a eight port hub if you have
something greater requirements like if
you would like to build a cluster with
more number of nodes let us say
something like 24 or 48 then you can go
for a switch and you can go for stacking
of switch
and you can build a huge cluster
so in the background of edge computing
device we are discussing what is meant
by a raspberry pi cluster
so if someone would like to ask like
what is a cluster a is a set of computer
connected computer nodes that work
together as if they are a single more
powerful machine
where there are different single nodes
which are connected to each other and
they are behaving like a single powerful
machine
so what are the questions that naturally
arise do they have their own operating
system each of these nodes the answer is
perform independent tasks or do they
perform the same task the answer is they
perform the same task yes
are they usually connected by some
networking infrastructure yes by some
high speed local area network so what
are the applications of this customer
cluster computing the applications are
like high performance computing
to deliver more performance than a
typical computer can provide
so these high performance computing
paradigm was usually used to solve
complex scientific and engineering
problems
like to give a simple example let us
assume that
we are given a set of numbers in an
array you set like 1 million and we have
to compute all the prime numbers
so we divide that huge
array into small
arrays and give it to each of the
node so that it computes the prime
numbers within it and all of that are
aggregated by the master node and
presented to the user
a common cluster size in many businesses
is between 16 and 64 modes
and it may range from 64 to 256
course
so linux is the dominant operating
system for high performance installation
so which are the famous linux
operating systems hpc we have suse linux
enterprise
and then we have the red hat enterprise
linux 8 these are some of the operating
systems to
note
now can a raspberry pi cluster become an
edge device
recently a kubernetes uh
was developed to manage clusters and it
was built using raspberry pi 4 nodes
and it was it was using open source
technologies like python and microsoft
technologies like c sharp and
is your machine learning models
so there have been instances where
people are building powerful edge
devices with raspberry pi's in a cluster
mode
now this is one of the way of looking at
things the other way is if you want to
explore exploit all these nodes in a
parallel mode many new libraries are
coming up in the world of machine
learning and deep learning
lfas is one of the examples which is an
extension of kira's library
so at the end of the day if this is the
platform which we are visualizing for
augmenting the cloud computing
capabilities by reducing the load on the
cloud computing and moving some of the
intelligent decisions to be made on site
through an edge device then naturally it
leads to the question like what are the
advantages of edge computing like i
mentioned earlier it reduces the data on
the network
so the bandwidth is cons conserved and
we don't have a lot of traffic moving on
the network
it reduces the latency instead of the
data flowing from your nodes to the
cloud and decision been taking and
returning back the decision is being
taken locally and the data
is visualized to be as more secure
because now it is at the premises of the
customer rather than on some remote
server on a cloud stored in some other
location so these are
naturally the advantages of having a
edge computing platform
keeping in this keeping this in mind so
our our work started focusing on
raspberry pi 4.
354 was uh
relatively recently launched somewhere
in 2019
and it is the state of these raspberry
pi
raspberry pi family of
machines
so what is a raspberry pi you can treat
it as a single board
computer right
so it is
it's having a very great powerful
processor so when you when you look at a
computer what are the things that you
focus on you first look at its processor
its capabilities
how much amount of ram it supports
what type of ethernet connectivity it
has so it can connect to the lan and
then to the global internet
what are the type of power supply it
needs
how much amount of display it supports
can we have two parallel monitors
connected to the same machine all these
facilities we start looking at it
because
it's a single on-board computer
so the processor that raspberry pi
provides is the cortex a72 architecture
it is a quad-core 64-bit rv8 processor
and it works at 1.5 gigahertz
this is the latest processor that sits
on the raspberry pi 4.
what is the ram so the ram
it provides raspberry pi 4 provides the
tiny computer in different modes like it
supports 2gb ram 4gb ram and 8gb ram and
it is based on the ddr4 concept so the
transfer speeds are drastically high
with the newest uh
it provides the support for the new usb
3.0 ports and also the usb 2.0 port so
there are four
ports two usb 3.0 and two usb 2.0
then it uses usb c port for the power
connection
and uh it has graduated from bluetooth
4.2 to bluetooth 5.0
it supports two micro hdmi cards for two
4k displays at 60 frames per second
using one raspberry pi
and finally there is the
way with each with the capacity of plan
increases and now we are speaking of
gigabit ethernet so the gigabit ethernet
connectivity is provided by raspberry pi
4. so this is our basic platform on
which our experiments are going to
proceed
now when we think of a platform it's
always good that we make certain study
before we either purchase it
config or install it
so i'm trying to utilize this platform
which uh
my data 2021 global conference
and num focus has provided to see that
the
participant
what are the components that they need
to buy if they have to assemble their
own raspberry pi machine so this was my
official list so
we have we it's better to always go to a
official raspberry pi kits because
uh
it's always safe like they meet the
requirements of that raspberry pi for
uh
computer so it's always better to have
an official keyboard
it's all
comes to the
memory card
or we call it as the sd card we need to
follow certain norms because
because there are certain compatibility
issues
i i went for samsung evo and i have gone
to
64 gb it is usually preferred to have a
memory card up to 32 gb greater than
that there have been some issues
but i have taken the risk and i've gone
for 64 gb and i've gone uh and this 60
samsung gearwork is at provides the
speed with class 10 and u1 compatibility
what is this class 10 and u1
compatibility i tell you in the later
slides basically it is supporting very
high speed transfer of data
then coming to the screen it's always
prudent that we have a screen which is
of small size because then we can carry
this tiny device along with the monitor
with us right so i've gone for the
raspberry pi 4 screen of 10.1 inches i
have not gone for the touch screen i'll
be it will be just a display device
now the greatest thing that we need to
keep in mind is the usb power supply
so i have gone for the official
raspberry pi power supply because it
gives the desired power to all the
components and the components can work
smoothly so the model that
i have purchased is raspberry pi for
model b 2019 it supports squad core 64
bit along with wi-fi bluetooth and the
main memory is of 4gb
now this entire thing was supported by a
generous stipend from num focus that
allowed me to purchase all these
components
when we think about the processor
raspberry pi stands for something called
as
so what is this arm it stands for
advanced risk machines
most of us are used to process which are
manufactured by intel and all they
follow the cisco architecture that is
complex instruction set computers risk
stands for reduced instruction set
these risk machines emphasize they
emphasize on registers
the smaller and so naturally smaller
instructions and thus can achieve very
high speed of executing you should all
know that registers are more closer to
the
computers than the main memory right so
this risk emphasizes the use of more
registers with the processor
also the smaller size of
arm processors and low cover low power
consumptions make them the most suitable
for miniaturized devices like raspberry
pi
now we all know that we need to have a
operating system that puts the
raspberry pi the famous operating system
is the raspbian
so again raspbian is based on dbn which
is a linux based operating system but as
highly customized for raspberry pi
so when linux evolved there were ma
various version various what you can say
brands of linux we had debun suse
mandrakes red hat
so red hat has red hat and fedora have
gone more to the desktop and other
high-end performing cluster computers we
saw the example of suse deviant has been
customized to raspbian and it is working
very fine with raspberry pi
so the popular versions of raspberry pi
are bg which is based on dbn7 jc which
is based on dbn 8 and stretch which is
based on debian 9
so even though raspberry pi can work
only with buster flavor of raspbian
which was launched on 26 2019
the os is still backward compatible with
other old raspberry pi models
so so far i've given you the background
of what components to purchase for
raspberry pi which is a kind of
recommended as operating system for
raspberry pi now we'll see how we can
connect our raspberry pi to a monitor we
connect it via our micro hdmi
cable
we need to connect the mouse and
keep board via the usb we need to
install the operating system so there is
something called as
there is a
manager for installing the operating
system and that's called as noobs it
stands for new out of box software that
makes our life easier to install the
operating system
we need to extract the noobs uh
downloaded and then this operating
system has to be written uh into our
sd card or preferably a micro sd card
like i was mentioning in my previous
slide so
it is based on a class which ranges from
2 to 10 2 being the slowest and 10 being
the highest plus the ultra high speed
class 1 makes the data transfer very
high
as soon as we log in we need to type
sudo raspberry pi
raspy config
and it allows us to have a screen like
this right and in this screen we need to
choose the interfacing options
and we need to change the password you
should know that the default login is pi
and the password is raspberry pi it is
recommended to change your password we
need to enable the boot to desktop and
we need to select certain international
options like language
time zone and the keyboard layout with
keyboard there is something interesting
thing that most of these keyboards are
configured to uk english and most of the
keyboards that we use are based on u.s
english so if you have not configured
the keyboard then some of your keys may
be available very funny manner so post
successful
uh instead of raspberry pi we can have a
wonderful environment
so now we have our raspberry pi we have
installed all these things now we need
to install the machine learning and deep
learning uh libraries python is
naturally supported by raspberry pi
during installation make it a point that
you upgrade all the installation
packages so all your network interface
your interface and your python 3.0 is
ready to support all your machine
learning and deep learning packages
so i will not be discussing over here
how to install all the machine learning
and deep learning packages because
that's a separate session in itself
we'll directly go to the topic of our
paper that how svm reacts to noisy data
and what are the issues computational
time issues with its training
data so we'll be discussing that why we
are taken svm as one of the
topics over here is
till the advent of these deep learning
algorithms and the more popular uh
ansible methods like uh deep learning xg
boost and light gbm
svm was the power performer in machine
learning algorithms it gave very high
accurate data in terms of
classification and regression and it was
like a kind of the preferred one right
but with the advantage of deep learning
support vector machines have become more
legacy systems and they have certain
issues what are those issues we will be
discussing through our
talk over here
svm basically works in a hyperplane mode
it tries to find a plane that supports
the maximum distance between the data
points of classes so here we are
visualizing a binary class it basically
tries to define a margin that provides
the maximum distance between the data
points of given classes
so here if you observe at the figure we
see we see that there is a large margin
which is the
thing that is needed plus we have data
points which are very close to the
margin which we call them as support
vectors and these influence the
orientation of the plane
so if we have two features we think of a
straight line if we have three features
we think of a hyper plane visualizing
more than three features is difficult in
terms of hyper planes
so what are the advantages of svm svm
has generally been proficient like i
mentioned to deliver maximum performance
in classification accuracy svm is
consistently found to be super superior
to other supervised learning methods so
svm comes under category of supervised
learning what are the disadvantages it
takes more time for training
and uh it does not perform well when the
data has more noise
we have taken deep learning multiplayer
perceptron as our benchmark to analyze
the performance of svm as you know the
deep learning algorithms have been
performing extremely well in terms of
performance issues so what is a
multi-layer perceptron it has a input
layer a hidden layer and a output layer
we call it as a feed forward network and
the learning happens through the back
propagation strategies so this is how
you build a deep learning algorithm in
kira's we
we initialize with the constructor
called as sequential because we want to
stack layers on one type of the one on
one top of the other
we add uh
we add a hidden layer along with the
input we add another hidden layer
density is used for building the layers
and the output layer has just
one neuron
we we try to compile it with optimizer
that is called as adam adam and the loss
and the metric for error is mean squared
error adam is preferred because it's a
highly efficient optimizer and then we
train using the predictors that is the
independent variables and the dependent
variable and finally the result will
tell us we are ready to test it for our
test data
so we have another benchmarking
algorithm that is logistic regression
and it is used as a most of the times as
a binary classifier to classify discrete
classes like whether a person is male
female cat dog pass fail
the
what we call it as the non-linearity is
provided by the sigmoid function
available with the logistic regression
why we have used it as a benchmark is
because it is very efficient to train
okay
so this was our first experimental
scenario we used raspberry pi b
and uh we saw that logistic regression
was the fastest and it gave us a
computational time of
37.81 seconds svm was the worst it took
3949
seconds you can imagine svm running on
deep learning it takes lot of time
so what we did here is we thought of
using the built-in sky kit learn
pipelining concept here it we scalar we
use a standard scalar function so fit
and transform the training data set and
just transform the test data set so
applying that we built a pipeline and we
used a linear svc because it is known to
be one of the
fastest uh
variant of support vector machine
to this we our data we added a gaussian
noise why we added a gaussian noise
because we wanted to test the robustness
of svm when noise is done and we saw
that when we saw in terms of
computational speed the speed of svm
increased drastically as compared to the
others and it became highly competitive
to deep learning but still it was
inefficient as compared to logistic
regression okay so then why do we take
logistic regression before applying svm
it is always a thumb rule that you apply
logistic regression and see the
performance if not go for svm svm gives
more better results but the
downside is the computational time
involved
so we use the area under curve to see
how our algorithms perform svm with
noise we saw the
area under curve if it is one it is
better that means it is able to classify
the discrete classes properly if not it
is a bit hazy
so we saw that with noise the svms uh
auc dropped from somewhere near 2.83
also the accuracy dropped to seventy
eight point
five eight percent from ninety nine
point nine percent so what is the
conclusion the conclusion is pipelining
architectures and automating machine
learning models has a good
impact on constrained environments like
raspberry pi
and svr model outscored dlan by 79.94
percent with gaussian noise in terms of
computational time but the bottom line
is svm is sensitive to noise we cannot
run away from it if the data is noisy
then we have to develop strategies by
which noise is eliminated from the data
set so that svm is better able to handle
it this is a thumb rule for all the
legacy systems which are still using
noisy data so
i just
ran my presentation a little faster so
that i may have sometimes to take
questions i take this opportunity to
thank pi data global 2021 organizer num
focus and all the attendees who have
provided me an opportunity to present my
work in front of you thank you
oh
thank you too doctor i'll give everyone
a
a few a few moments to
the type up and whatnot
yeah
i've certainly not like i've of course
got a raspberry pi myself i've never
done anything quite that advanced i just
have it hooked up to a 3d printer
run it okay great great what it has
oh oh we've got we've got one in here
thanks have you considered using a
jetson nano with gpu on board
yeah uh yeah
that's that's a really great question
like uh
gpu
is meant for deep learning and is meant
for more powerful machine learning and
jetson nano has provided a device
similar to raspberry pi
but uh as i mentioned in my earlier
sites to begin with i would like to
build a cluster with raspberry pi
because i have more control over it but
in future definitely i would like to
migrate to jetson nano some of the
things with jetson and was to begin with
it was relatively little costlier for me
but in future definitely i would like to
build a cluster with jetson nano
and jetson nano is the way to go but the
only thing here is
i personally believe that raspberry pi
has a more
dominant community let us hope in the
meantime that jetson also comes up with
a more vibrant community and
reduces our learning curve of uh
installing all these uh
deep learning and machine learning
packages and
is
is more receptable
platform uh
all right that looks like the last one
uh
i'd like to thank you again and i'm glad
to be your host and uh
you you enjoy the rest of the conference
and the rest of the weekend
yeah
yeah a wonderful day doctor
yeah thank you thank you steve